c'est un bar pas tout à fait comme les
autres
à l'arrière d'une robe gris on va faire
d'abord les pastilles de la vaisselle
ensuite on va faire la crème à récurer
et on finira par notre recife pour le
linge on vient ici pour étancher sa soif
de connaissance
c'est un bar à lessive un nouveau
concept qui draine ces années ces
nouveaux convertis pour fabriquer des
pastilles de la vaisselle par exemple
recette est simple les cristaux de soude
du bicarbonate de l'acide citrique du
gros sel de l'eau et puis on rajoute des
huiles essentielles d'accord et c'est
parti pour une heure de préparation
respecter les dosages mélanger malaxer
objectif fabriquer par le menu ses
produits d'entretien sans additifs
chimiques
ces tendances quand on achète un pot de
bicarbonate ski et coûterait cher
souvent c'est l'emballage on se rend
compte qu'on vous qu'on jette beaucoup
d'emballages donc pas terrible pour la
planète
donc l'idée c'était de se dire comment
on peut fournir ces produits-là et
répondre à une demande une attente
écologique
donc d'où l'idée du bar à ce qu'on
appelle le bar à lait si c'est à dire
qu'ici est derrière moi on a tous les
produits qui permettent de faire ces
produits soient même ouvert il y a trois
mois à peine
le bar à lait si fait désormais le plein
à chaque atelier
le bouche à oreille sans doute la
curiosité certainement la nouveauté pour
sûr je suis venu parce que j'en ai marre
d'utiliser les produits qui sont vendus
avec un différents éléments je ne
connais pas et j'avais envie de
travailler avec des produits nettement
plus naturel voilà et donc c'est la
première fois que je fais ça
mais voilà ça me permet de là en
l'occurrence ça permet de tester
différents appareils et principes et ses
cultures bien et si effectivement ça me
satisfait et pour l'instant ça en a
l'air
je vais pouvoir poursuivre et puis
continuer sur des produits plus
biologique est ce que votre curiosité
satisfaite attendait parce qu'il faut
que je voie après
6 efficace ou pas savoir à l'avancé donc
là vous avez fait trois produits donc la
crème à récurer les pastilles de la
vaisselle et la lessive pour le l'âge
qui vous reviennent à 10 euros au total
fabriquer soi-même son liquide vaisselle
pouces et adoucissant la barre à lessive
propose déjà de nouvelles compositions
six ateliers affiche complet jusqu'en
avril